so i have these two molecules here
propane on the left and acetaldehyde
here on the right
and we've already calculated their molar
masses for you and you see that they
have very close molar masses and so
based on what you see in front of you
which of these you think would have a
higher boiling point a sample of pure
propane or a sample of pure acetaldehyde
pause this video and think about that
all right
well in previous videos when we talked
about boiling points and why they might
be different we talked about
intermolecular forces because you could
imagine if you have a bunch of molecules
let's say in a liquid state the boiling
point is going to be dependent on how
much energy you need to put into the
system in order for the intermolecular
forces between the molecules to be
overcome so that molecules could break
free and enter into a gaseous state
and so when we're thinking about which
might have a higher boiling point we
really just need to think about which
one would have higher
intermolecular forces
now in a previous video we talked about
london dispersion forces which you can
view as
random dipoles forming in one molecule
and then that can induce dipoles in a
neighboring molecule and then the
positive end even temporarily positive
end of one could be attracted to the
temporarily negative end of another and
vice versa and that whole phenomenon can
domino
and we said that you're going to have
more of those london dispersion forces
the more polarizable your molecule is
which is related to how large of an
electron cloud it has which is related
to its molar mass and when we look at
these two molecules they have near
identical molar masses so you might
expect them to have near identical
boiling points but it turns out that
that is not the case the boiling point
of propane
is negative 42.1
degrees celsius
while the boiling point of acetaldehyde
is 20.1 degrees celsius
so what makes the difference why does
acetaldehyde have such a higher boiling
point why does it take more energy for
the molecules in liquid acetaldehyde to
be able to break free of each other to
overcome their intermolecular forces
well the answer you might imagine is
other things are at play on top of the
london dispersion forces and what we're
going to talk about in this video is
dipole dipole forces
so you might already imagine where this
is going
in the video on london dispersion forces
we talked about a temporary dipole
inducing a dipole and neighboring
molecule and then them being attracted
to each other
now we're going to talk about permanent
dipoles
so when you look at both of these
molecules which one would you think has
a stronger permanent dipole or another
way of thinking about it is which one
has a larger dipole moment
remember molecular dipole moments are
just the vector sum of all of the dipole
moments of the individual bonds and the
dipole moments are all proportional to
the differences in electronegativity
when we look at propane here on the left
carbon is a little bit more
electronegative than hydrogen but not a
lot more electronegative so you will
have these
dipole moments on each of the bonds that
might look something like this
so you would have these things that look
like that if that is looking unfamiliar
to you i encourage you to review the
videos on dipole moments
but as you can see there's a symmetry to
propane as well so if you were to take
all of these arrows that i'm drawing
if you were to take all of these arrows
that i'm drawing and net them together
you're not going to get much of a
molecular dipole moment you will get a
little bit of one but they for the most
part cancel out
now what about acetaldehyde
well acid aldehyde there's a few
giveaways here
one is it's an asymmetric molecule so
asymmetric molecules are good suspects
for having a higher dipole moment
another good indicator is you have some
character here that's quite
electronegative in this case oxygen is
quite electronegative and even more
important it's a good bit more
electronegative than carbon so right
over here this carbon oxygen double bond
you're going to have a pretty
significant dipole moment just on this
double bond it might look like that
and all of the other dipole moments for
all of the other bonds aren't going to
cancel this large one out in fact they
might add to it a little bit because of
the molecule's asymmetry
and so net net your whole molecule is
going to have a pretty significant
dipole moment it'll look something like
this and i'm just going to approximate
it but we're going to point towards the
more negative end so it might look
something like
this
pointing towards the more negative end
and i'll put this little cross here at
the more positive end and so you would
expect a partial negative charge at that
end and a partial positive charge at
this end
and so what's going to happen if it's
next to another acetaldehyde well the
partially negative end of one
acetaldehyde is going to be attracted to
the partially positive end of another
acetaldehyde and so this is what people
are talking about when they say
dipole-dipole forces we are talking
about a permanent dipole being attracted
to another permanent dipole and so
acetaldehyde is experiencing that on top
of the london dispersion forces which is
why it has a higher boiling point
now some of you might be wondering hey
can a permanent dipole induce a dipole
in a neighboring molecule and then those
get attracted to each other
and the simple answer is yes it makes a
lot of sense you can absolutely have a
dipole
and then induced
induced
dipole
interaction and we might cover that in a
few examples in the future but this can
also occur you can have a temporary
dipole inducing a dipole in the neighbor
and then they get attracted to each
other and you can have a bit of a domino
effect you can have a permanent dipole
interacting with another permanent
dipole they get attracted to each other
and you could have a permanent dipole
inducing a dipole in a neighboring
molecule